desean stop liking jersey swaps and let
me
run off has told me to give you this how
do i force them to trade me
james harden issues heartfelt tweet to
houston i have to speak to the beard
this stop is diamond heights before you
enter we have a few
on written rules that is why we don't
leave gridiron heights now entering
hardwood hills whoa athletes get to just
go wherever they want
too much autonomy lost little boy
oh great more new people kyrie i swear i
don't know these guys
if we're a super team why don't i feel
super
so you want to cause a scene in houston
now publicly insult your teammates what
uh
do it uh jj watt's head is too small for
his body
look i'm sorry i can't do this jg's head
is perfect i guess i'm trapped
are you my new daddy
[Music]
written rule number 34 if anyone's
having a really good day no one can talk
about
it no ordering a grand slam from denny's
if you've already eaten that day
no enjoying your job out loud if
someone's car has hit every green light
on main street they get to run stop
signs to keep it going
your neighbor's music's too loud you get
to peg them really hard don't write any
of these rules down that's why this list
is blank